foreign
is starting off this hour in Sioux Falls
South Dakota hey Ryan welcome to the
Ramsay show
thanks Dave it's honor to speak with you
and John you too what's up
I am wondering for my wife and I it now
is a great time or is the right decision
to take out a home equity loan to finish
our basement
and make substantial renovations to our
house oh
what a uh uh uh you know we're we're not
the home equity loan business around
here we're in the get out of debt
business so
um what makes you think that we would
tell you to go into debt to do this
um well I normally wouldn't but looking
at the website and reading some of the
information on your website it obviously
it doesn't advise home equity loans
uh it does say however that if there was
a time to do it it would be to make
Renovations substantial renovations to
your home
on this website if it is I need to know
where it is so I can punch somebody in
the content team and have that taken off
no that shouldn't be on I think you were
reading Motley Fool
no I I promise I I searched Dave Ramsey
home equity loan it took me to Ramsey
ramseysolutions.com it had a whole
write-up on home equity loans and it
talked about
um you can go ahead and pull that now so
that we can get that pulled I'm sorry
apparently there's someone inside this
building that doesn't understand what we
do we'll have to work on that that
happens sometimes we hire new people and
they have to be trained I'm sorry you
got bad information no we don't tell you
to take out a home equity loan ever wow
never done that one time in 30 years so
um yeah sorry for the mistake that's
awful that we misled you that way
um now let's go back and try to figure
out your problem though and solve it
rather than just slapping around the
issue um
how much home what does it cost to do
the basement and what's it cost to do
the other Revenue the other renovation
two different numbers and what do you
guys make a year three different numbers
uh we uh it's kind of kind of tough I
live in a commission based in a company
that I haven't worked a full year but
roughly take-home pay is around 125
000. okay
um the renovations again rough rough
guess on you know just average square
square footage cost per square foot for
the basement probably somewhere in the
uh 25 to 40 000 range depending on on
what we'd want to do
um and then just some other Renovations
um probably in the neck of somewhere 45
45 50 000. in addition to the 25 and 40
in the basement
no no no no no sorry
total package 45
000 top side uh of that uh 10 or 15
upstairs and 30 downstairs
yeah yeah okay all right uh well let's
just break this project up into uh
slices that we can eat that we can chew
and save up the 15 000 and do the
upstairs and then save up to 30 000 and
do the downstairs do you have any money
yeah yeah we do it was just more just
again looking at the weather do you have
any money how much money do you have
uh well we're still in the Pro and it
wasn't necessarily like a do immediately
right now um we have a little bit of of
debt that we're cleaning up we're
working the snowball it was more just
like in the next few months would this
be something that we think about doing
um no so no we don't have it we don't
have
um very much money because we are
working the debt snowball okay how much
money do you have
um yeah right around the you know that
thousand dollar emergency fund and then
we're at cash flow and pretty much
everything else to the debt okay and how
much debt have you got
um we have just a little over ten
thousand dollars in student loan debt
good
um and then uh they have about uh a
little less than twenty thousand dollars
on uh just personal personal loan oh so
you got thirty thousand dollars left to
go and you're acting like that's gonna
happen in 30 seconds
so saving thirty thousand to do the
basement shouldn't take long either
yeah after you're out of debt
so yeah again I apologize for our
website having bad stuff on did you find
it I did it just says here's what you
can use a HELOC for if you get one it's
saying this is what common uses are
doesn't recommend it it says it's debt
right after that and then it says why
you shouldn't okay so it says on there
not to do it but it just says some
people do this but we are we say don't
do it okay so I guess it wasn't our our
content people they get punched you
misinterpreted the article okay yeah
yeah that's good I feel better yeah
I mean you've got a thousand people in
the building sometimes somebody Goofs up
you know yeah absolutely
um
yeah it's almost like I I he read into
that email what he wanted I mean that
blog what he wanted
yeah he wants to do this basement and I
got a feeling he's gonna do it anyway
yeah absolutely yeah that's the way it
sounded um but here's the thing
the answer to the question you need to
always set um
set the bar out into the future
somewhere
like and okay here's the bar I want to
be wealthy I want to be I want to be a
baby steps millionaire so that I can be
outrageously generous and change my
family tree okay then once you say that
then you say What is the
shortest fastest most
probable way for me to get there
the the highest probability in the
shortest time for me to get there it's
not borrowing on a HELOC to do your
basement right it's uh paying cash to do
your basement and then you don't have
the basement uh following you to work
every day so to speak and so no uh and
you've got you know the the same
information that convinced you to get
out of debt should have convinced you to
never make this phone call because you
should have been saying I don't ever
want to go back in debt so something's
broken here right
and I unders I just did this at my house
Dave my back my back patio if you will
it's a deck it was old it fell off I
mean it was falling off the house and so
I had kind of trashy it was I had to
have somebody come out and look at it
and I said hey
um there was an issue with the with the
way they did the post on my front I have
a long long front porch that goes across
the whole front of the house give me a
price on that too while you're out here
and they they looked at it all gave me a
great price great deal
I had the cash
to do the one on the back and he's like
man I got you a deal I said I know it's
great let's do the one on the back and I
didn't like it and that's what we had to
do that's the cash we had right and we
got a great back deck and now I've got a
plan for if we're gonna move on to do
the front one yeah fix the fixed front
porch I think and here's what's funny
now that I broke it up it's gonna be
several years because it falls back on
the priority list but had I been doing
this with a loan I just want to let's go
ahead and just do it all right I would
have spent money I don't have as a
project that isn't a Do or Die project
right now
100 of the time whether you're buying a
shirt a car a deck a house spending
borrowed money
activates a different place in your
brain emotionally than spending your own
money
some people call it real money
like when you're spending real money
versus other people's borrowed money
then you you just you make different
decisions
and uh it causes you to process these
whole Pro these whole things differently
who you hire as a contractor is even
different this is the Ramsey Show